When you've been in
some situations where life
wasn't going your way,
what were some of the
ways, the tools,
the words of wisdom
that helped keep you going
when times were tough?
There have been a couple
bear markets for me before,
and every time you hit
that low point where you
sort of think like,
what's going on?
I think ultimately it's just
realizing that if what
you're building has some level
of real impact on society,
market cycles come and go,
and eventually the market
will come back.
And as long as you've
built something real,
the bear market is the
best time, because there's
less people fighting for attention,
there's less hype cycles,
narrative cycles.
So people building
real infrastructure really do have
the time to shine.